la parole est à Monsieur Pierre Charron
pour le groupe
UMP
monsieur le président
madame les ministres
monsieur les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2014 est une fois
de plus
symptomatique de la politique d'un
gouvernement socialiste à la française
les entreprises et les contribuables
sont plumés et les épargnants et les
investisseurs sont dépouillés pour
redresser les comptes sociaux le
gouvernement a une fois encore choisi
d'alourdir la fiscalité alors que nous
devrions
et après vous être obstiné en séance
publique à alourdir les prélèvements
sociaux sur les produits de placement
vous avez reculé pour annoncer que seul
l'assurance vie et ses contrats
multisports prisés par 7 millions
d'épargnants seront concernés par le
projet mais c'est encore trop et comble
de l'insupportable curieusement vous
avez annoncé à la va-vite que la mesure
s'appliquait déjà avant même d'être voté
à compter du mois de septembre dernier
pour éviter tout comportement
d'optimisation
anticipative nous contestons la mesure
pour plusieurs raisons tout d'abord du
point de vue de sa lisibilité son aspect
rétroactif a pour désastreuse
conséquence la rupture du pacte de
confiance entre gouvernants et
administré et l'encre l'idée d'une
instabilité fiscale et l'esplaner comme
l'épée de Damoclès rappelé par le
questeur d'herio la possibilité à tout
moment d'augmenter rétroactivement les
prélèvements sociaux trop de Français
quittent la France déjà 35
lacets par cette fiscalité confiscatoire
et entravé dans leur liberté
d'entreprendre elle met à mal la
pédagogie de vos prédécesseurs visant à
faire de l'assurance vie une source de
financement d'amélioration des retraites
d'une part et d'autre part une réserve
de capitaux visant à financer les
entreprises françaises
elle donne le signal d'un sacrifice de
l'épargne à long terme au profit de
l'épargne à court terme il y a une
incohérence sur laquelle vous ne pouvez
fermer les yeux le privilège serait
accordé au contrat monosupport dont la
contribution au financement des fonds
propres des entreprises françaises sera
de plus en plus faible au détriment des
contrats multisports investis en partie
en fonds
à la veille de la création d'un nouveau
contrat euro croissance destiné à
orienter l'épargne vers le financement
des fonds propres entreprises
l'instabilité fiscale est juridique la
perception que peuvent avoir les
épargnants de ces mesures spoliatrices
ne peuvent que fragiliser son démarrage
enfin si la rétroactivité fiscale
imposée par la mesure pose un problème
d'égalité entre les contribuables
s'ajoute un problème d'iniquité entre
les détenteurs de contrats monocytor et
ceux des contrats multisports investis
en fond garanties pour un investissement
sur un même fond les environs
s'appliqués les prélèvements sociaux au
fil de l'eau au taux de chaque année les
autres au moment du retrait ou au décès
au dernier taux connus dont on peut
parier qu'il sera toujours plus élevé de
telles dispositions
ne peuvent rétablir la confiance
encourager les investisseurs les
investisseurs pardon qui ne se
détournent de notre pays elles asphyxie
notre économie ce sont des mesures
incompréhensibles en parfaite
contradiction avec les engagements pris
par le Premier ministre lui-même en
faveur des placements dirigés vers le
financement des entreprises la
compétitivité
l'investissement et le développement
durable débattre du projet de loi du
financement de la sécurité sociale est
une prérogative majeure du Parlement
nous devrions prendre nos
responsabilités pour permettre à la
solidarité nationale de s'exercer tout
en sauvegardant les équilibres
financiers en réalité ce pelvss allonge
une liste de nouvelles charges fiscales
c'est de la facilité en faisant peser la
majorité des mesures d'économie sur le
médicament qui leur présente que 15% des
dépenses de santé en revanche les
réformes de structure se font encore
attendre sur la carte hospitalière
l'offre de soins la spécialisation les
établissements la question des désirs
médicaux bref ce texte n'est pas à la
hauteur loin sans faux c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous ne le voterons pas je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues